بالفتره ليست بالبعيده الماضيه نتحدث عن
اصابه حوالي 80% من ابقار الاردن الحلوب
بالحمى القلاعيه وفق نقابه البيطريين
بالتالي بين الحمى القلاعيه من جهه
والجنون البقر من الجهه الاخرى كيف ستعامل
الاردن مع هذه الازمه
يعني انا بدي اشكرك على هذا الاهتمام وهذه
المتابعه دائما احنا في الاردن سياستنا
واضحه من خلال منع الامراض العابره للحدود
من الانتشار منع دخول امراض جديده الحفاظ
على الحاله
الحجريه البيطريه بصوره سليمه وبنفس الوقت
دائما نسعى لتعدد مناشل الاستيراد اليوم
لدينا ما يقارب 19 منشا الاستيراد لحوم
العجل والحيوانات الحيه بحيث انه نامن
احتياجات المواطنين في الشهر الفضيل ان
شاء الله طيب السيد حازم منذ سنوات منذ
عام 93 تحديدا لم يسمع العالم بجنون البقر
متفشي هل هناك مخاوف من ان تتكرر هذه
الموجه ان هذا النمط مستبعد
هذا امر نمطي يمكن كان كمان كانت في حاله
في البرازيل في ثلاث تسعه 2021 ظهرت عندهم
حاله مشابهه استمرت لفتره قصيره جدا ومن
ثم تم السيطره عليها حتى اليوم حاله جنون
البقر مثل ما تفضلتي اللي ظهرت في
البرازيل هي حاله محدوده في حالتين
مختلفات النشر عنهن على الموقع الالكتروني
للمنظمه العالميه لصحه الحيوان بعد التاكد
من من من طبيعه المرض والتاكد من من انه
بتحدث عن جنون بقر وفق الفحوصات المخبريه